hello everyone this game I'm about to
show you was played between Michael Tao
and a very strong Russian Grandmaster
Afghani what'd you cook once you could
want a couple of very strong open
tournaments during his career and she
was a six-time Moscow national champion
and if you're wondering about the title
of the video well we'll get to that part
soon so let's see the game Michael Tao
is white and Waseca is black table is
efore we have c6 to the caro-kann
defense Knight to c3 c5 d 4e captures on
d4 I mean you get there's only four
sorry about that not cappers on e4
Knight to d7 93 9 to f6 Knight to g3 e 6
Bishop to d3 c5 tau castles what you go
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
now Bishop c5 então retreats the knight
Knight to f3
so achieve of castles we have Queen e2
by tau b6 preparing to develop the
bishop bishop to f4 Bishop to b7 rook a
to d1 Knight to d5 attacking this Bishop
on g4 so Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen Queen to c7 and towel plays nice
to h5 and when I see this night to h5
move I always remember what to bottom
Enoch said about styles games he said
that tall just puts his pieces in front
of his opponent's king and well at a
certain point he's your sacrifice is one
of them so we'll see this is true for
this game as well a simple place King
th8 making room for the rooks on the G
file
Bishop to e4 so as you cook place f6
kicks the bishop away Bishop to h4
Bishop to d6 the her that born on h2 and
in this position tau plays a very strong
no he plays c4 and this is a very strong
move because this night can never move
if you move stone will capture the
bishop on b7 and then pick up this pawn
on e6 for free so in this position of
Asuka actually has a couple of good
options
he could play f5 a textile bishop
he could play rook to e8 and after tall
captures the nice and d5
he will capture with the pawn and then
tell the bishop on e4 will be pinned
from the reckoning 8 and there is also
another option and their option is a
Bishop to a6 pinning this form so the
point cannot capture and this is what
what you have played but in this
position and this is a where we get to
the title of the video here
tal was really trying to calculate this
move Knight captures on g7 but tell
himself said that this move was so
complicated to calculate there were so
many branches of the variations and he
simply couldn't calculate all of a
Supercenter replies so after a while tal
said he started thinking about a about a
hippo drowning in a swamp it's an old
Russian story for children and thought
was really thinking about how to save
him from drowning so he considered
everything using Jack's ropes
ladders helicopters and after a while
and by a while I mean 40 minutes of
thinking tells that well I don't see how
I can save the hippo just let him drown
and here it all says that after he
looked at the position he understood
that this Knight sacrifice was purely
intuitive and that if he can't calculate
it and probably massacre can calculate a
leader so he just played it nice
captures on g7 and it seems the boss
Vinick was right even for this game so
we have what Zuko plays King captures on
g7 and not nice to be 4 so here tall is
threatening to capture this pawn on e6
and fork the Queen and King
so what you have defended with nice to
see 5 and tau plays Queen to g4 check
and by playing this coin to g4 checks
tile actually unpinned
from this bishop and now the black King
has to move so we have Kings to h8 and
now tau plays nice captures on the on e6
[ __ ] the Queen and rook so we have
Knight captures an e6 and Queen captures
captures on e6 and in here what you go
again has plenty of replies and
probably the best reply would be to
capture this born on h2 just picking up
a pawn but I don't know I guess after
after towel it starts coming for you the
last thing you want to do is grab
another bond but you have to look at the
position this night here is attacked the
night cannot move because the rook will
be hanging from the bishop on e4 and
taking all of this into consideration
was you have played a rook a to e8
attacking the Queen and getting his rook
out of the pin so tau captures the piece
and in this position what you have took
Bishop captures on h2 Kings to h1 and
now what's the vertical place Queen to
f4 and our simple is threatening to
capture this Bishop on h4 but here tau
finds a very nice tactic cell plays
Queen to h5 and now tile is threatening
checkmate on h7 but tau is also dropping
this piece on e4 so this Bishop is going
to fall so but you cough captures it and
here tau plays rook to e1 now the Queen
the Queen cannot move because tal is
attacking this rook on e8 with the
rookie and the Queen and also this
Bishop will fall as well so what you
could place Queen to g6 and offers to
exchange Queens so towel capture screen
captures and g 6h captures on g6 and now
Bishop captures on s6 with check so the
bishop cannot be captured esta would
capture the rook on e8 so we have King
to g8 and natal captures rook captures
on e8 rook captures ne8 and King
captures on h2 and of course Bishop to
c4 and if you look at this position this
is common in in a lot of health games
after the song after the storm calmed
and after you count the pieces and
everything well we have a rock ending
with opposite colored bishops and the
towel is the pawn up and well you
totally consider this to be a draw but
it stalls move and so plays rook to d7
and this already
attacks the pawn on a7 and it cuts off
the King from entering into the position
so this is a very important thing to
notice so
the roof that's attacking the bishop
bishop to c3 and here what you have
capture the pawn he is going after it
because well as many points as you
exchange ferry will draw so tile
captures the pawn on a 7 with rugcutterz
on a 7 we have Bishop to c4 King to g3
and now tau starts to improve it at the
position of his game bringing the King
into the game so we have Bishop to b5 f3
King to f8 Bishop the d4 attacking that
point so point to b5 and King goes
deeper into the position King gave for
Bishop to c4 King to g5 King td8 rook th
check and the reason towel played this
rook to a check and now we'll have a
repetition of Moses probably because
this is new for T so towel was probably
trying to reach your time control so we
have King test f7n towel retreats with
the rook rook to e7 check
so King te 8 and now B for fixing this
pawn on b4 so it can be attacked
we have Bishop to d5 rook to a3 King to
f7 and our G 4th rook to e2 Bishop to c5
rook the e5 check King goes to h6 Rock
to eat six now rope to the three
attacking the bishop bishop goes to c6
and now South plays rook to d8 as you
can see now it's threatening rook to
that face checkmate so we have rook to
e8
offering the exchange of rooks and also
place a rope to d4 we have roped the e6f
4 we have king te 8 teleplays King to g7
Bishop b4 and now tile finds a very very
interesting tactic a place
Bishop to b6 and if the bishop is
captured well towel will capture the
light squared bishop and this is a one
endgame
so in this
vasu cook plays Bishop to f3 attacking
that one on g4 but here Tao finds
another interesting movie plays erupted
eh check and after King to e7 he plays
rogue back to thee three and well this
is a very interesting variation what
happens if the bishop captures this pawn
on g4
so if Bishop captures on g4 I would play
Bishop to d8 check and after King tes he
would play Bishop to g5 and well black
is completely lost here there is no
defense against the roof to d8 only
defensively to play rook to e7 and give
up this rook but this would be quite
losing so after towels roof to d3 what
you could played Bishop to e2 attacking
the rook here table rook Bishop to da
check so we have Kings to e8 and now tau
attacks the bishop
rook to d2 and if you look at this
position well black is pretty much
without a move but he has to make a move
so he plays rook to e3 and now tau plays
Bishop to g5 and again in a very simple
position like this doll is controlling
black's pieces and also threatening
checkmate mdh once again so what you go
here tries Bishop to d3 just to block
the rook from coming to d8 and not
helpless f5 and in this position but you
could resigned so what would happen pal
is attacking it was ego stroke on e3 so
you would have to play something like
rook there three towers push f6 and
after something like Bishop to c4
because now tel is threatening to
capture the bishop and after the rook
captures just push f7 so wish to see
four probably must be played and in this
position simply King captures on g6 and
what all these two points up and this is
completely winning so yeah a very nice
game by tau I think a very instructive
game especially how to play the opposite
bishop color the darkest color bishop
endings and I do hope you enjoy the
story about the drowning hippo and one
more thing as of yesterday I enabled the
nations to
channel and receive a $1 donation from a
username tributon so I put his name here
you can see it above my head
so thank you thank you sir it means a
lot and as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I do hope you
enjoyed this game and I'll see you soon